I love the movie so much and you and
your husband wrote it and you guys are
such a good couple you have so much love
your soul
romantic with each other whenever you
come on I always love to talk about your
relationship because I totally idealize
it and it and it but it's and I
appreciate it well I'm the real deal
thank you for saying that I mean we
really do love working together and we
wrote this in 2020 like right at the
start of lockdown and it was really nice
to have
something to do write a creative Outlet
because we couldn't be on sets working
as actors and it was nice to find a way
to connect as a couple in a different
way like being trapped at home all day
every day like everybody you know we had
this new thing that we could do together
no I always I've always had a fantasy
that I would meet someone and then we
would write together and I've never
gotten to do it so may I ask like do you
go into separate rooms and come back
with stuff do you sit in the same room
together do you talk it out is it
everything
above it's it's mostly sitting in the
same room together Dave's at the
computer typing I'm like I'm like I'm I
will also be at the computer typing and
then five minutes later I'm like
bouncing off I have to be moving talking
acting out the dialogue and that's
mostly how we do it taking my clothes
off just kidding it's true a little
because your character has a really
great idea for a documentary I really
loved the subject matter that your
character is interested in and I thought
there was great validity to it thank you
a lot of it has to do with nudity
um as well we talked we're sort of
creeping around yeah nudity is something
I appreciate you not spoiling anything
but we did yeah I mean that's the poster
though it's freaking I'm sorry but I do
miss streaking I'm sure that's taboos
agree we wrote streaking into the story
because I love streaking I'm a fan too I
was streaking a few nights ago in La
before our Premiere oh were you in the
hallways of the hotel oh my God
okay we had a story in the news about
first dates oh sure um and how it's you
know according to this one woman she's
advocating for sex on that first date my
younger self says yay my older self says
nay right did you and Dave what was your
first date how do you feel about the
concept
well I think I've told you that Dave and
I met at Mardi Gras together
so maybe you can deduce whether or not
we had sex on the first night
um
I'm an advocate of it you know like
because you want to kind of know what
you're getting into like don't you want
to know if you have that chemistry with
someone I think that's the woman right
away is like do you want to know right
out of the gate what you are
like together yeah the chemistry like
what if you dated someone for two weeks
and you're having all these great dates
and like you like have a lot to talk
about and they have a great sense of
humor and then it just doesn't work well
together in the bed I'm not saying like
there's a mechanical issue on anyone's
part I'm just saying what if the two of
you are like a mismatch right wouldn't
that be a bummer I remember one time I
waited like I like this guy so much that
I made us wait like four months oh my
gosh yeah lots of heavy petting and
making out but I don't know I was just
like you know make him want it make them
wait make them fall in love with me we
finally do it and he broke up with me oh
and I don't think it was I know it
wasn't based on the sex because he had
said I think we're just in very
different places and I think you're
looking for a real relationship and I've
played the long game by the way I now
wish that that woman's article would
come out sooner
truly I mean truly because if you had
slept with him on the first date and
then he left you're like I mean whatever
great we had one nice day
right away yeah oh you know what yeah
This Woman's article is brilliant yeah
it led to a very happy prolific
beautiful Union you and your husband are
a phenomenal couple in fact can I play a
voicemail that that Dave has okay
um so this is Allison leaving a message
or calling you're talking about it's
actually like a voice note that he
recorded of me when I was a little
intoxicated okay take a listen
huh
let's try it in fifth
it's what it's contributing the knife is
because his character of his true
character I think
[Music]
[Applause]
it's things from early in our
relationship that I go like wow I can't
believe Dave stayed with me like there
are some early voicemails to your point
that he has recorded where there's no
game it's like we had gone out a couple
times and I'm leaving in voicemails that
are like
I just like you so much
you're hot and like why do you want to
date me I love it and I love you like
this is like we barely knew each other
two weeks and he was like I'm in
[Applause]
a women
um if men could make it safe for us to
be expressive and silly and
unarmored I love your husband and may
this be a lesson to all people to just
like go with it and have some fun and
not make us feel also sick and
vulnerable thank you
hope everything all the time so thank
you Dave yeah we should be able to
express ourselves oh my God
and you have a little payback because
there's did you bring a photo no one's
ever seen yes this is the night we met
must be 21 to enter and I was so I did
now last time you were here we played a
game of unicorn ring toss there we are
well you want to get it on again you
know I want to get it on me too oh
it's time we're gonna play a favorite
game of yours cornhole I love corn I
love corn dogs
[Applause]
[Music]